THE CENTERING PASS INTENDED FOR
KARAANTA HELD THE POST.
NOW HIS HERE.
GOAL!
FILIP CHYTIL MAKES IT 1-0 NEW
YORK.
WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE OPEN.
IT AROUND.
AHO IS THERE FOR CAROLINA.
NEW YORK OUT IN FRONT TODAY.
.
NEAR OFF THE RIGHT WING FOR
ROONEY.
WALL.
TOP.
HE DIVES ON TOP OF THE PUCK TO
SMOTHER IT WITH SPLIT MOVE
AND ANTTI RAANTA WALKS RIGHT
INTO MAKE THE STOP.
CONCERN FOR NEW YORK.
LINDGREN MISSED THREE IN THE
OPENING ROUND.
THERE'S A SHOT RIGHT ON BY
KOTKANIEMI CHYTIL.
AND RAANTA H KAKKO, AND CHYTIL
STANDING ALL ALONE ON THE
IT.
RAANTA HAS RESPONDED WELL.
SEAN:TO THE FAR WALL BY RAANTA.
A
GREAT SAVE BY RAANTA, ANDD.
CAME OUTHIT THEBOTHINETLE
LIGHTNING HERE.
AHO THROUGH THE SCENES.
FOR NEW YORK.
HERE IS KAKKO.
IS NOT A PENALTY.
IT IS A NON-CALL.
OT THE
CROSSBAR INCHES AWAY FROM TYING
IS PERFECT.
DEAD CENTER OVER THE SHOULDER,
OFF THE BAR, AND IT STAYS PASS ]
THERE IS ZIBANEJAD.
THE BACKHAND ONHE
BOARDS.
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT IN THE
POSTSEASON.
THEY DO NOT REDUDUNA WINS GAME N
OVERTIME 2-1.